hey everybody and welcome to an insane
wild ride with stevo this one's insane
in the membrane folks we've got the
legend to be real who's a good friend of
mine from way back in the day but i
haven't seen him since i got sober man
it's crazy he just lets loose talking
about gang activity being shot
like what doesn't he just totally open
up about this episode is literally
insane and what's not different about it
from any other episode is that i'm
pounding coffee the whole time but what
is different is the coffee that i'm
drinking four sigmatic man this stuff is
made with functional mushrooms lion's
mane mushrooms if coffee made with
mushrooms sounds weird to you trust me
this stuff is delicious man except it
doesn't give you that cracked out
jittery feeling it helps you stay on
point it boosts your immunity all of the
mushrooms that they make it with are
organic and fair trade i'm telling you
man i heard about this from my friends
they use it they swear by it and now it
is the only coffee that i will drink and
you know i drink a whole lot of coffee
so they've given a special offer only
for the wild ride listeners exclusive to
the wild ride podcast if you go to
4sigmatic.como
you can get up to 40 percent off your
order of any coffee bundle
and free shipping i'm telling you this
stuff is gonna really help you out so
help out the podcast help out yourself
go to 4sigmatic.com
stevo and try out this coffee which is
the only coffee i will drink now because
man i want to be on point i want to
regenerate my brain i heard that this
stuff might actually
regenerate my brain which i could use
because i beat up my brain a lot but in
any case get on over to force this
4sigmatic.como
enjoy up to 40
off of your order and free shipping and
now
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen be real yeah
dude
yeah man good good to see you man uh you
met scott and paul yeah what's up dude
have i not seen you since i got sober
yeah it's been some years yeah dude [ __ ]
man i've been sober 13 years
congratulations on that dad thank you so
much man
yeah you were privy to what a pile i was
[Laughter]
was the last time you guys saw each
other at the rainbow room yeah they
probably would have been drinking at the
bar
i think i dropped him off at the
apartment you were staying at at the
time we got off actually i went with you
into the apartment something was going
on and then you rammed your [ __ ] head
through the [ __ ]
through the drywall
like
at the apartment yeah oh what do you
mean like the night like that was
with the guy named stomper i think so
yeah
right b reel had the best friends man
that they got these guys are the stomper
and uh
guitar big marv there's a big mom
how's he doing uh he's good he's slimmed
down
you know he's he's uh
toned his party life down a little bit
because he's a little bit older and you
know
you can't you can't grind
all the time every [ __ ] day like
these guys were but yeah he's doing all
right he's doing all right you guys hung
out quite a bit back in the day yeah our
spot was the rainbow yeah and so like
and this was before marijuana was like
legal it was like kind of [ __ ] up to
just sit down at a restaurant and be
rolling joints and smoking them on the
patio
right and and it was just cool there
yeah we made it like little amsterdam
yeah you know i was tight with the owner
mario rest in peace mario magliaria a
legend on sunset strip
and his family owns the rainbow the
whiskey in various places um
and when i got there i was introduced to
him by this this guy named big worm rest
in peace who just passed away you've
partnered with your biggest dick yeah he
passed away recently he got out of
prison and
maybe
six months later he passed away but i
got to see him before uh
before he passed
um but mario allowed us
to be on the patio
smoking weed he got a kick out of it he
didn't he didn't smoke himself he didn't
do any of the drugs he just maybe had a
drink but
he allowed everybody there to
be themselves and and do what they do as
long as they didn't act like [ __ ]
get in fights and [ __ ] like that which
did happen but
you know we kept it together when we
were out there it was more about just
hanging yeah and and having a good time
yeah i remember um one time
you had a bit like a big boombox cd
player on the table and you played for
me
psycho realm yeah and uh that [ __ ] was
so dope i stole your your cd man
that [ __ ] was great man shout out to
psycho realm man sick jacking yeah that
was your first time hearing it i
remember because you know we had i think
we had put that album out in 97
and it had been around for a while but
we were talking about it
and then i just brought it and and you
got a chance to hear it and you took it
and that was good because that's what
that's what it's about
us is artists keeping cds it never
happens you know what i mean we want
someone i think you might have left it
like
on the table and then i was like oh
that's mine yeah yeah
yeah coke off this later
or chuck it at somebody yeah oh man i do
not cherish that thing man to to this
day i i love those guys yeah um so dude
there was a story that we heard about uh
why you saved his life david you saved
my life
this was uh maybe you at least saved me
from getting my ass beat maybe it could
have been
because back in the day like way back in
the day um like 2003 2004
um i had been disrespectful
uh to the insane clown posse there was
something like they
they i was trying to say they're not
real clowns because i had gone to clown
college whenever i was just out of my
mind on drugs just being a dick wad
and uh
talking about like oh man like you could
come on stage but they weren't wearing
their makeup they don't want to appear
without their makeup on right right
right like all these guys everything
they won't come on stage or whatever i
was just being a dick and so they
decided that the next time they saw me
they were gonna [ __ ] beat my ass try
to jack you up
they were gonna they were gonna give me
a thumping and uh and and they showed up
at the rainbow and said there he is all
right man there we go and then they
started sitting with you and they were
like oh [ __ ] we can't do that be real is
our boy yeah we go back
and uh
we've done many shows with them and
many you know
different sorts of conversations that
have happened you know the history of of
cyprus and icp
and so you know you know there's a
mutual respect there so they saw you
sitting there with me and they were like
no no we're not going to do that yeah i
did i love those guys now man i mean i'm
i'm full on hatchet man tattoo too hey
man when we're young and on one man it
just doesn't matter like we don't think
about [ __ ] we're just
going and doing it we don't give a [ __ ]
who we offend or if somebody gets
defensive or whatever you know i mean
it's we're just going
and then we realized later oh [ __ ] maybe
we're really dickish right now for sure
and i think that like whenever like
whenever you pop off in some kind of uh
you know
celebrity way i think there's growing
pains involved you know like you can't
you can't go from like nobody knows you
and then everybody knows you and not
like
have some kind of like acting out like
yeah there's there's
for for for what we do right so like
hip-hop music and for the lane that you
came from there is no school for it yeah
it's all learning it as you go along
there you know there's no guides there's
no teachers to tell you this is the way
you should be going don't [ __ ] around
over here
and
you know it's it's those growing pains
those bumps in the roads and
fortunately for us you know we've
managed to go through all those bumps in
the roads and all that [ __ ] and still be
here
and that's you know is it sorry is it um
different
popping off like you guys popped off
when mtv was like
everybody was just tuning in to watch
mtv or the radio and like they didn't
have cell phones and you guys weren't so
easily accessible to everybody like
what's the difference in stardom
like in you know 2001 at the rainbow
room when somebody sees you or going
somewhere versus like now where you know
you might be everywhere all the time and
you get what i'm trying to say like is
it yeah what's crazier to pop off in 98
or to pop off in 2021
it was harder to pop off then but people
got more excited about you back then
because i mean you know there was more
mystery there you know less
accessibility to to you as an artist oh
[ __ ] and and and all that they had the
sort of like
treasure hunt right info or their way
too
whereas
this day and they just like we're giving
it to you like here it is
you ain't got to find nothing right here
yeah and and so i think some people
still get excited and [ __ ] for artists
but it's it's it's not like it used to
because that mystery was a part of it
right when are they going to drop
how are they going to drop it and you
know like there there was there was no
there was a build up by record companies
by putting out snipes and promotional
pieces and [ __ ] like that but it was all
like
you know like a road map to getting you
hyped up about the artist or whatever
product right
these days it's boom right in your face
from the jump
you know less mystery i feel like if
somebody sees you guys now they're like
oh dude oh my god crazy can i get a
selfie okay bye right back in the day
they'd like follow you yeah you know
like let me just trip out on this guy
for a minute because i'll never get to
see him again i i first
started listening to cyprus hill in 93.
when did you guys first cd come on 91 oh
wow okay
you came on through on black sunday
probably around that time right yeah
dude i was a kid man i mean [ __ ] dude
like what i guess i mean i was 19 at
that point but
how old are you now i'm 51 now damn yeah
yeah so i'm uh i'm 47.
and dude we've been at it for a long
time a long time i just saw you outside
i'm like dude we're still going
look you know what's a trip man imagine
if technology that exists now existed
back in those crazy ass times man
i mean
you talk about viral because the [ __ ]
that that we were doing way back then
right was just way off the chain you
know um
and
you know it in some ways we're we're
sort of glad that that that technology
didn't exist back then because some of
that [ __ ] was just a little over the top
but yeah
tommy lee was telling us that dude he's
like man we got away with straight
murder uh people would a lot more people
would be getting canceled right now for
that [ __ ] yeah you know because
the rules were different back then
you know and uh
that i think that's
the technology has put everything at the
in your face like immediately
you know from from if if you're trying
to be
like
so as artists
when you become an artist you get any
level of run right any level of success
you're giving away your your um
your privacy basically sure that's the
sacrifice but you you got to deal with
that because that's a part of the game
and if you're trying to fight against
that it always works against you you
know what i mean like
how how um some of the actors back in
the day used to be like
[ __ ] these paparazzis and getting in
their faces right right throwing their
[ __ ] cameras not realizing that if
you just gave them the couple of seconds
they were going to leave you the [ __ ]
alone and be cool with you but the more
you
you know were pushed them away
they will antagonize you even more
because they know oh you don't want this
[ __ ] right unless you're giving them
better photos when you're freaking out
on them yeah man and that's and and and
that type of [ __ ] made it to where
everything has to be a world star moment
yeah you know what i mean the viral
moment that they can catch
and those are the things that you got to
deal with now but you know
you got record companies who feel like
maybe the the album itself
the promotion of the album or whatever
the product can be a viral moment and
it's not necessarily like that for
everybody for like a drake yeah
you know and and guys like on that level
the minute they put something out
[ __ ] get excited in their face
there's no
mystery there's no lead up there's boom
here it is and instant reaction yeah
these [ __ ] surprise like midnight
just
they just put out an album and it goes
ballistic yeah that's insane yeah before
you used to have to build up to that
okay the album is coming out in three
months we need three months of promotion
leading up to
where these days it's like
yeah here's the post let's go
if you got a robust following
um that is you know that that that will
engage yeah i mean it's gonna it's gonna
be here's a link buy now instead of
going to the warehouse or going to the
easy easy entire records easy a click
away now dude we've talked to a bunch of
people
in here
and
for all the people i asked hey were you
aware that there was a time when i was
trying to become a rapper and nobody
remembers it nobody
not only does be real remember my rap
career he actually contributed to it
which is just so crazy man what a bro
like my friendship with him really is
meaningful you know what else is really
meaningful the information that i get
from my whoop band you guys who are
regular listeners absolutely know what a
fan of my whoop band i am and if you
don't know what a whoop band is it's the
most sophisticated fitness tracking
device known to man and i have the most
exciting news about it they're coming
out with the whoop strap
4.0 and i'm inviting you guys to be the
very first people to try it out along
with me oh man mine's gonna show up in
the mail any day now and the new 4.0
loop strap has way more information it's
going to give you like your oxygen
levels your skin temperature i mean dude
and it's smaller it's smarter the the
charger that slides on to it is
waterproof now oh man this is so
killer and if you've already got a whoop
membership with six months left on it
then uh you upgrade absolutely for free
if you're a new person to whoop and you
need to be on the whoop game then boom
you sign up you get the ban for free
and uh 15 off at checkout if you use the
promo code stevo at whoop.com that's
w-h-o-o-p
com i mean dude this tells you
everything that you could possibly want
to know about your sleep your recovery
how many calories you're burning like it
is just off the charts impressive and i
love it and i cannot wait so go to
woop.com and use the promo code stevo at
checkout for 15 off and
get on board with the whoop
4.0 man
yeah dude
now let's talk about rap
after your be real remembers
didn't we do something
together
and and uh
and do your verse on that [ __ ] track
we recorded was so dope
it was so [ __ ] dope and just like
everything i did on the track was just
awful
but uh i didn't want to give you no wax
[ __ ] yeah
but he's doing a redemption album pretty
soon i'm trying to do it i'm trying to
like get organized to do uh some
redemption [ __ ] and like whatever just
make it fun and funny let me know
dude let me know
the track that you and i recorded it was
called if i died today and the the whole
like the the whole gist of it was you
know what [ __ ] if i died today i
killed it man i'm still stoked on on
what i accomplished when i was
when steve's writing a rapper i i always
ask
i really just appreciated the [ __ ] out
of that thank you
man oh you know we're boys man i had to
give you that fire
all day
so cool when you're writing a song what
hits you first i know it's different for
everybody is it the lyrics or do you
have to hear the beat first
well some you know sometimes i'll get
ideas without the beat
and i'll just sort of mentally store
that away till till something comes
along that complements that idea like
rock superstar for instance that was in
my head
for um some years before we actually put
that out years yes
and aren't you worried you're gonna
forget it no well with something that is
like um
that strikes you heavy like you you know
you know it's a good idea
you'll hold on to it and you'll remember
it and i was constantly like just
waiting for the right music
to happen you know mugs
gave me many um
styles of of of beats and and and uh
you know
different options to write to you know
throughout all the albums you know and
what i wrote was basically
what i felt when i heard the music right
so that's the other way i write i when i
listen to the music the music speaks to
me as to what i should be writing about
or what the concept about or or if it's
just one of those rapper brag brag the
[ __ ] you know brag about yourself
cause there's that too right but we've
always tried to write cohesive songs
that mean something and [ __ ] like that
so i try to go where the beat takes me
yeah i mean and but with with um
songs like rock stupid superstar and
there's a couple other ones but that was
obviously the biggest one that i held in
my head for a while um it wasn't until
mugs came with that particular
you know bed of music that you hear as
the song now
um where i felt like that's gonna be
great for this idea here so i i did that
and at first it was just rap superstar
and donnie einer from
columbia records he was
you know one of the one of the big wigs
in the industry period says
think you need some rock guitars on that
and we're like
oh
okay because you don't say no to donny
and mugs went and put the rock guitars
but then he had the foresight to put the
orchestral parts on it and made it like
you know it was like um
us
us being led zeppelin of hip-hop in that
and
with that song that was our cashmere
yeah yeah know what i mean that's that's
that's how we looked at it like this is
our cashmere it's cool and so that that
was one of the ones i had in my head for
years uh you know
other stuff i came up with on the fly
you know like like dr green thumb for
instance i got to the studio heard that
music
boom dr grantham and i made that song in
like 45 minutes something like [ __ ] what
about the tunes that american psycho
was that with d12 yeah that was d12 that
was that [ __ ] track is so fire man
yeah they were killing it yeah they they
had the idea actually they they hit me
up and they were like hey we want you to
do this chorus
um
and they sort of give gave me an idea of
of what the song was about and then like
what they kind of wanted me to say but
like say it in my own
on my own terms in my own way and and so
that's that's what i did there
and i thought man that it is a [ __ ]
tight song when i hear it i i took it i
i took that and went and did a mixtape
and put a verse on it
with with me and right okay because i
remember
like hearing it and then trying to look
for it and i was like i couldn't find it
yeah my the the one with my verse on it
is is from one of my gunslinger mixtapes
i had that's right yeah three volumes i
had three volumes uh there was uh
gunslingers there was gunslingers
fistful of dollars um a few dollars more
and something else it was all the clint
eastwood right run right yeah that's
what the problem was man i'm glad we got
to the bottom of that because i got to
dig up that track man i love it so much
oh yeah and then people started hitting
me like how did that not make the d12
record i'm like well i did it after yeah
they only asked me for for a chorus so
that's what i gave them if i had the
foresight to just
send the verse and be like hey i sent
this verse too yeah just in case
remix style
but i didn't i didn't do it i didn't
want to like impose it and then you know
having to be like i don't know
i know i what i did there but
i don't ever want to force my [ __ ] on
someone sure you know what i mean like
if you don't want it
cool
so instead of sending it i just held on
to it and used it for my mix tape and
was like [ __ ] nice go here dude it's
unbelievable it seems like the shorter
it takes you to write a song the bigger
the hit sometimes
sometimes you know like because you're
feeling
something in that moment and you have a
certain momentum coming from the
universe yes it's coming from somewhere
else it ain't coming from you when it's
like that it's coming from somewhere
else you know what i mean like for sure
with green thumb because with with green
thumb
um it was a sketch i wrote for the radio
show that i was hosting at the time
because we were doing a friday night mix
show eric bobo and myself called soul
assassins radio there's a soul
assassin's radio now from dj mugs on on
uh sirius xf uh xm
but before that it was on 92.3 the beat
fm here when that was
yeah theo on the radio yes and julio g
was also on this this uh
station right so i would write sketches
so our mix show was like a saturday
night live with mixes because we would
do all the voice overs myself
bobo and our our partner quasi who was
our production guy and we'd get all
other artists to do voiceovers in these
sketches
and so we wrote one in a in the sense of
you know
it being like uh infomercials were big
at the time
and so i wrote an infomercial style
commercial for dr green thumb a
cultivator and
you know it was based off of me and my
boys growing weed because we we had
always done that we were pretty goddamn
good at it so you know
the nickname green thumb came from that
because you know you would see nurseries
out throughout los angeles or southern
california with that green thumb meaning
you're good at growing weed right so
that's
the idea popped off from that sketch
when i get to the studio and i hear that
beat
the sketch is in my mind on this beat
like oh [ __ ] this is the song and i i
just start going in
and uh we end up using that sketch to
that song
yeah you know what i mean um so it all
sort of just came together like
out of nowhere but when i when i got to
the studio and i heard that beat
all the ideas for that song along with
that sketch start rolling out and
45 minutes later it's laid and locked in
and i think i laid it at 10 in the
morning
on a [ __ ] thursday or something like
that and
muggs knew he was like this is the [ __ ]
right here b's gonna [ __ ] slay this
right here
and the funny thing about that song is
that
record company tried to get me to change
it they wanted me to do
switch the lyrics and make it more like
an insane in the brain part two or
something like it i said no i'm not
going to change nothing and we already
got insane in the brain and i'm like why
would i do that again
that would be redundant i'm sticking
with this and they're like
radio ain't gonna play it but okay it's
a great song
and i'm you know to this day i'm glad we
stuck to our guns because it became one
of our biggest songs
in terms of our our fan base just that
being one of the anthems and it was a
big a big hit in europe no less we were
tripping on that and uh it sort of made
its way into the pantheon of top
cypress song so like
just as a you know to give you a
an indication right so
we play insane in the brain there's a
pop that happens with that right
people explode they go crazy it's nuts
mosh pits and you know
stage diving all that crap right
fast forward to now we do when we do
green thumb it's the same reaction
and they didn't think that was gonna
happen they thought it was a waste of a
song and for me that that was like
it was a
something that happened organically and
it was
the it was the luck of the day because
who knew that that was going to become
my cannabis brand yeah i had no clue you
know
we always envisioned you know being able
to do this or that in the cannabis world
but we didn't know when we didn't know
how we didn't know what we were going to
do we just knew we'd be a part of it
somehow
but boom that song became
my entrance into
you know the the cannabis industry that
that's what was so special about that
song that that's why i say it came from
somewhere else because that song led me
somewhere else other than music
weren't you uh in the business of the
vapes like the vape machines before that
well you know we had friends that would
make the
the vapes like the ones that you see now
like are the volcano and stuff like that
not the vape pens that right right right
right like the the the bag that fills up
yeah
yeah there was so many of them i
remember they they brought okay so like
if you go get your car tinted right one
of the things that they'll peel off old
tints
or dry the new ones is this [ __ ] heat
gun
and there's a [ __ ]
a lot of heat that comes out of this so
someone said okay we're gonna make a
[ __ ]
you know a vaporizer out of this [ __ ]
heat gun we put it in here it [ __ ]
you know it blows up the bag it was
before the volcano but actually it only
burns the crystals right it yeah there's
no smoke baking the crystals yeah so
there was that there was the heat gun
and you know who knows what kind of
damage we were doing to ourselves a
[ __ ] thing right
and then you had the the the pieces that
would heat up like it was like a [ __ ]
iron inside a box yeah and you put the
[ __ ] tube in there with whatever
flower you had at the end of that tube
and you would pull it
it wasn't like something that was
um you know blowing it to you or
exhausting out to you you had you had to
hit it there was a number of them and
they would all make their way to me
because
i mean you know we're dr green thumbs
yeah
so
i had a number of them but i you know
like some some folks made me some uh
some personal ones and then there was
ones they tried to sell in the market
but there was really no market for them
because they were [ __ ] illegal and if
the smoke shop got caught selling one of
those back at the time they risked their
[ __ ] their their license you know
what i mean so
there was a lot of them out there though
there was a lot of people trying to make
those [ __ ] things yeah i remember
yeah um i just i saw this uh this
documentary series on netflix called
murder mountain yeah which was like
really fascinating crazy about humboldt
county and how like when it was sort of
like the prohibition era of growing pot
all these people would go missing and it
was like
super crazy but the way that that series
played out they almost made it sound
like the the marijuana industry was way
better off before the legal legalization
because now like they they tax everybody
like all this regulation it's like
impossible for these small farmers to
make any money at it like do you have an
opinion about like the legalization
can we quickly stop to agree that be
real is pretty much the coolest dude
ever you can ask the guy anything and
he'll give you a completely honest
answer i love that you know what else i
love i love the fact that the wild ride
listeners really seem to be pretty into
having sex
why because
blue chew is a hit with the wild ride
listeners what's blue chew well chewable
tablets that have the same active
ingredient as both viagra and cialis
except it's chewable and only costs a
fraction of the price what does that
active ingredient do
it makes you hard as a rock
and evidently the wild ride listeners
like to be hard as a rock because it's a
hit with you guys and if you haven't
tried it why wouldn't you man it's a lot
of fun to have an extra rock hard boner
when you're enjoying sex and you know
what else is great about bluetooth
tablets you don't have to go to some
awkward in-person doctor's appointment
no no no you go to bluechew.com and you
consult with one of their medical
providers right there on the website it
is super fast super easy and that is all
you got to do to get your bluetooth
tablets and start having a really good
time you know what else is great is that
i can get you an entire month's supply
completely for free if you use the promo
code stevo at bluetooth.com
yeah dude all you have to pay is five
bucks for shipping and you got an entire
month's supply of bluetooth tablets for
free i mean dude come on let's enjoy
rock hard boners and great sex how does
that sound because dude if you do that
with the promo code stevo get the whole
month supply for free at bluetooth.com
not only are you supporting the podcast
not only are you gonna be hard as a rock
but dude
you don't even have to pay
just five bucks for shipping so do that
go to bluechew.com use the promo code
stevo and now
let's talk about legalizing weed
yeah i mean you know that that was
something a lot of people worried about
in when when um
it
first became legal because there was a
lot of stuff that people didn't
understand in the legislation that would
eventually affect
um small businesses independents you
know mom and pop type of right you know
companies that were trying to come up
but nobody saw that you know everybody
you know
the folks that were deeply invested they
just saw legalization and they didn't
give a [ __ ] how it was going to affect
the small guys right but in any business
when you're trying to legalize it you're
going to give regulation and you're
going to get taxes and that is the
bottom line on any business so that's
the sacrifice that that
you know we had to think about as as
people in the industry that like okay if
we're going to make this legit and make
it legal
we have to scale up we got to scale up
and and we got to abide by this now it's
it's it's hard to adapt when
you know obviously now you got all these
regulations you got to have these
licenses and permits and all this and
that costs money right
you know that affects your bottom line
and then now you got to produce on top
of
you know that you got to make up for
what you just invested in there because
if you don't got the capital
it's [ __ ] tough to to exist in that
way and and i think the people that put
the legislation together they knew that
you know and and it's it's
a lot of us that said it that that when
it came you know those of us that had a
strong brand and a strong name
in the in the industry
we wouldn't be
affected the same way right and you know
in some places i got [ __ ] on because i
was talking about you know what we
should
wait
to legalize this [ __ ] here because the
legislation
ain't in the favor of of the small
business
owner you know it's gonna wash you guys
out there's gonna be this big ass wave
whoever survives the wave
is going to do great business and
there'll be a strong brand
and they'll be able to survive in what's
coming when the corporate money comes in
those of us that don't survive we're
just going to wash away we're gonna have
to sell our licenses and [ __ ] like this
right and that's exactly what the [ __ ]
happened so i i could understand why
some of those folks up there wanna just
unplug and not be a part of
of the [ __ ] but if you're trying to be a
legal brand
or a legal retailer
you know
it is what it is right now you know it
costs to make it cost to be in this
business but once you get it going and
once you get your momentum and
you know like cookies is a great example
i mean you know they started with one
store
and a huge hype on their name and
the expansion that they've had has been
incredible yeah you know and we're
pretty much right behind them in that in
in terms of our expansion we're about to
you know push to to open
many stores outside of california now
here in california we got six
so
you know
um
it's all about trying to get your brand
right
and adhering to the [ __ ] rules and
regulations that the and and
and just
operate
the way you need to right now so that
they they don't have an excuse to take
your licenses away or to you know stomp
your [ __ ] brand out because i mean
realistically it's
i think
you know our taxation here in california
is very high which is unfair like
there's no industry that gets taxed the
way the cannabis industry does wow
is it like 20 25
higher than that
yeah then california is already the
highest and then with cannabis oh yeah
there there is no
um we get no reprieve
and realistically cannabis sort of
helped california through these times in
the pandemic because a lot of these
shops
were allowed to stay open as essential
businesses because you know for some
people it's medicine
you know what i mean and i would say the
cannabis industry has held california up
i mean it's it's revenue that it didn't
have i mean even the entertainment
industry was leaving california because
it was too expensive to operate here
right and do production here so they'd
go somewhere cheaper that's been going
on before the pandemic
yes since way before the pandemic
you know so california needed the
revenue
and yet our taxes are so [ __ ] high
you know i think they need to fix that
well i know they need to fix that but
that's that's a part of the [ __ ] it's
unfair to all of us but
imagine that
you know
people that have partners that are let's
just say
um
they they're funded
that they you know they they have funds
to to make it through this way people
that aren't funded
wiped well and plus two like getting
into the weed business it's like a lot
of these people were on the black market
before i'm like oh [ __ ] let's get legal
and then they get legal and then they're
like okay cool where's this money coming
from they're like well i can't really
like document where it's coming from
yeah and somebody just don't want to pay
the taxes
right i mean you're making all this
money and you're not paying taxes you
got your overhead and you know what that
is most of these guys know what their
[ __ ] is and they know what they got to
do to make x amount
but it feels good taking it all in
and not having to give nobody nothing
but that's not the way it's like great
how are you going to fund this well i
can dump like 500 000 and okay cool can
you document where that came from
because that's the other thing yeah and
at that money ain't even taking your
banks
you know till it's federally legal
across the board
banks aren't really going to take your
cannabis money
indian reservations will though yeah
yeah they will but that's risky yeah you
know what i mean that that's risky any
any of that is is definitely risky but i
mean you got to do something
and so you know you open up a laundromat
next door and watch the money
yeah
we had the craziest conversation with
tommy chong and and i asked him like
about how much more
powerful marijuana has become
since like you know like the 70s or
whatever right and he shocked the [ __ ]
out of us saying it's not more powerful
it's the same plan it ever was like
well look i gotta disagree with my
mentor there
sorry tommy i gotta disagree with that
oh we were confused too we were like oh
i mean
i can agree
that it's the same plant yeah but but
the the technology and and right the
science the like the understanding of
how to like make this a super plant has
just advanced it's like working out like
for a human being right before
um in the 50s in the 50s athletes didn't
have supplements you just know your your
basic food groups that you should have
but there was no such thing as
supplements now there's trt now there's
just every [ __ ] supplement in the
world to maximize and make your workouts
efficient and work for you right still
the same person blood bone
dna all that [ __ ] but it'll knock you
out but we'll knock you the [ __ ] out
because
we're stronger
you don't want to put a 1950s nfl team
um
right they don't have a chance right as
great as they were back then they were
great with what they were dealing with
at the time right there's advancements
in everything right so along with
technology you know there's advancements
in nutrients for the plants to
um promote the different things that you
need the plant to do for it to be what
you want it to be right so they didn't
have
these things back in those days and most
of those dudes were growing outdoor yeah
you know and now there's these these
teas that you could use for for outdoor
cultivation where people were just you
know some some folks were just watering
their [ __ ] or home remedies
and stuff like that now you know not to
say that the dudes in the 60s and 70s
you know
some of them knew what the [ __ ] they
were doing like pro
but when you think about how many of
them there were it was a small number
most people were growing what we call
today boof
stress weed swag boo boo swag you know
what i mean that you were [ __ ] yeah
commerce [ __ ] you wouldn't give to your
enemy you know what i mean
um
that bad no i'm saying right and so yes
there were there's always been talented
growers in every
every
decade or every since its existence a
few small talented
groups in different cities different
states but these days there are more
talented cultivators why because
knowledge is out there
the the you know you can
you can find the way to do this [ __ ]
right if you got the money and you got
the right place and you got the set up
and it's clean and
you know
you got the the the right guidance you
could per you could produce
awesome cannabis and there's more people
doing that today than there was back in
that day and right and the cannabis is
definitely stronger because because you
have these
the you know you have the technology and
you have these supplements for the
plants
to make them better
so last time the last time i bought weed
was over uh like in 2013 at on first in
alameda at the arts then there's some
dispensary right there and they're like
[ __ ] it just came out 13 flower thc and
everybody's getting high as [ __ ] now
it's like 33 percent
you're speaking in tongues after you
take a rip
like i couldn't handle that [ __ ] do you
have like
like a special like
like that like lo like where you're like
okay dude i don't even want to take on
the 33 but like like for tip for this
morning like i got to get some [ __ ] done
i'm gonna like yeah go for some weaker
[ __ ]
yeah i mean i think every every
cannabis brand has its it's very you
know it's it's impactful [ __ ] and
the ones that you can function too you
know i mean we all have to have that
because if you want to sell to every
type of consumer or connoisseur
you got to have it
you know something that's like for the
the rookie the novice
something for the pro right you know and
not only that you have to have the right
bud tenders that have that knowledge
that can explain that to them are you a
first time user are you in the middle or
are you
fully blown professional
are you an indica or a sativa smoker
um primarily endica but you know i i've
been doing a lot of exotics and hybrids
these days you know so it's a mix sort
of both sometimes
indica dominant sometimes sativa
dominant
um before a show
oh yeah
no no obviously but before show indica
it doesn't matter you have a specific
weed before show it doesn't matter what
it is for us it's you know like as long
as it tastes good and the impact is
there
you know we'll smoke it before the show
whether it's indica or sativa primarily
we always smoked indicas because we used
to be snobs about every other
strain if it wasn't kush og kush the
real og kush um if it wasn't that we
wouldn't even [ __ ] with you you know i'm
like ah no hold it we'll we'll smoke
some of ours with you you keep your [ __ ]
it wasn't until um
i'm gonna say
maybe 10 years ago that i started
smoking other flavors outside of oge
because you know one of my good friends
we had run out of weed in in san
francisco on this tour but i knew there
was wheat out there but there's net we
could never find any good og out there
everything else bomb but you could never
find some og like southern california og
out there
so i called one of my boys jp from west
coast cure i said hey
we need something we rent we just ran
out
what do you got oh i got tahoe oh gee i
got platinum cookies i got this that i
said you know what let me try those
platinum cookies i've been hearing about
these platinum cookies or just cookies
for the last six months at the time
and he was like i got you no sweat
and he brought it rolled it up and boom
i was like oh [ __ ] this is really good
and that opened my my palate up to start
smoking different [ __ ] other than og so
like i started smoking all sorts of
different strains out there and then
the flavor boom happened where
everybody's developing different flavors
different exotics different crosses and
[ __ ] like that and to me that's great
because i mean we like options it's like
if you just had one drink would you be
happy with that yeah
yeah for sure
i remember like way back in you know
when it was like 2003 2004 2005 we were
filming wild boys and this was just like
travel to a different country every
every [ __ ] time we go out and there
are certain parts of the world where i
just knew because they'll like [ __ ]
kill you if you get caught with weed
there it's you know like
indonesia like you know like anywhere in
the eastern hemisphere yeah like
and and for those trips what i would do
is uh
i would grind up a bunch of
weeds put it in a condom and tie it or
not and swallow the [ __ ] and then fly
and everything flush it out yeah and
then i get to thailand i get to like
where india you know and i'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] it out and smoking it and uh
that's how i determine or
like i mean that's you taking it there i
mean that's the only way that you're not
you know right yeah that's the safest
way to try safest way to take it
right but it makes me wonder like like
did that rule out like large
like parts of the world for cyprus hill
tours like you can't like
work yeah i think
more than anything it's it's
in places like that they you know if a
promoter tried to bring us there they'd
get [ __ ] with just because our subject
matter on cannabis and then all the
street [ __ ] that we talk about and
i mean not so much political [ __ ] but
some of it is talking about
you know
how authorities stomp down obviously you
know a lot of us they come from now we
talk about that and anything that would
give people a thought like to say [ __ ]
authority or to
to do
a thing that they consider an illicit
drug
they ain't having it so like places like
that they would never allow us to go
even if we wanted to go
we wouldn't be allowed to go
unless we were gonna take out all those
things in those songs
which we couldn't
it wouldn't be the same thing
i'm a psycho yeah
yeah hi we're cyber sales good night
good to see you yeah yeah you know how i
could just kill a man
i don't even know how we would have to
flip that you know what i mean so some
of these places it just yeah are the the
subject matter of any of the songs just
don't fly in some of the places so
we can't go in
the same way with with my [ __ ] man like
uh you know like my tour i can't i can't
go to like the middle east and [ __ ] oh
yeah no we could not go there
you're not going to be doing the double
back and you know right and i would i
would love to go there but i know
the type of [ __ ] we talk
is not acceptable down there at least at
least from what i heard you know on the
street [ __ ]
like i've never thought of you as like
like just like watching youtube videos
just you know i'm getting ready to talk
to you today
like
it was like i was like wait like blood
stuff like gang [ __ ] like i just never
thought of you that way you know like oh
yeah uh i was running wild before we
were making records um i was
how you know i guess i was considered a
badass kid
you know i was i was very uh to myself
but when i got involved with the gangs i
was pretty much a soldier you know
and uh
with with within a gang you have your
own gang you know so let's just say
there's 200 of us and we're from the
same block and we claim this block this
is our gang right
not all of us hang out and not all of us
get along the same way but there might
be five or six of us within that 200
that are our own circle
and that we hang tough and [ __ ] like
that
and you know we always stood within our
circle i mean we
we were a part of everyone else too but
we were the tightest over here and for a
time yeah man i i ran
in in this one circle within our set as
we call it yeah um
and we were running [ __ ] wild i mean
um i got the name be real through
you know the gang bang life
um because before that
you know sam and i we've known each
other before that i mean since sort of
introduced me to the bangers that i
eventually
got down with but i knew sand dog way
before that because hip hop was always a
thing for us like it was a hobby that we
all
or or something that we loved it wasn't
even a hobby yet
we started rapping and [ __ ] for fun and
and it did become a hobby but i sort of
straight away and got into the gangs and
and send dog and his brother melo man
nason dj muggs
they took it serious they took the music
serious they were constantly trying to
push to that
i was out there [ __ ] you know
running really wild i got shot
everything
and uh you got shot oh yeah in the lungs
well yeah it so
we were um
there was like maybe five or six of us
we were in another neighborhood another
blood neighborhood but
their neighborhood is constantly at war
with these guys that are their rivals
with their practically nav neighbors so
walking through their hood if you don't
know their get down you might get caught
up and that's what happened you know
we didn't know how he did their little
war was in in their own neighborhood we
were oddly enough going from one house
to grab some weed to come back and party
at the house we had just left from but
we didn't take it we didn't take a strap
with us meaning a gun
and uh
a car pulls up in front of us
they're all wearing blue hats
we're wearing red and [ __ ] and so as you
can imagine all the [ __ ] talking starts
and none of us are pulling anything out
and i you know i noticed that really
quickly and i saw the [ __ ]
gun coming over the front seat
and then the [ __ ] driver the the
passenger had it and he starts letting
off on us he hits one of my guys in the
elbow
the
bullet travels from the elbow and comes
out and gets stuck here
they thought they killed him because of
the way he the way he reacted when he
got hit so they switched the gun and
they're they're trying to get me now
they take four shot or he takes four
shots on me the fourth one ricochets off
the wall i run into it
so i could hear him
tucked and then the fourth one
catches up to me boom and and i caught
it
right here on the side in the back
and i didn't feel my lung collapse yet
it was when i hit the corner and i
looked to see if they got out of the car
to chase
chase us down with it but they hadn't
they kept you know they shot they kept
going
that's when i collapsed because my lung
had had been pierced
they i got hit with a 22 hollow point
still in me like there's a fragment here
fragment here and a fragment back there
so yeah that was uh
that that happened on imperial in hoover
wow
you got hit oh i knew it was yeah it
felt like a charlie horse
when did that happen that was in
1986 oh damn maybe 85 85 86 i was 15 16
years old wow
a lot of us at that age had gotten shot
i mean a few of my friends at that age
had just gotten out of
um
uh y.a which is a
you know like a prison yeah well it's a
prison for for youth
that eventually are going to go to the
real prison like you know there's
there's juvenile hall
and that's like a county jail for the
youth you know you're it's just
basically
you know they're holding you until they
figure out if you're going to ya or
you're going to get probation or some
[ __ ] like this right
why a is the serious thing for the for
the youngsters
because it's like a prison
because it's like a prison it's a junior
prison
security gym now yeah so some of my guys
you know that were my age and in my time
they were banging they would get out
from maybe the six months or the year
that they had to do for whatever
and one of my one of my homies came out
he had he had a big reputation as young
as he was
he was known for being a shooter and
when he got out
they rode down the block found him and
they killed him that day i think he had
been out maybe a week
if that geez and that's that's how crazy
it was i mean it it it was a war zone
man got to tell you
ice cube talks about going to y.a and
hid the hood swall
yeah well that that does happen
he didn't do it you know what i mean
like he was portraying things that he's
seen in his life
from friends we've both seen that you
know what i mean i actually lived it for
a while so you know i seen
some of my homies come back like that
they you know they go in skinny young
kids and come back monsters
you know monsters ripped up 17-inch arms
at 16 years old i'm like what the [ __ ]
because i never went to y a you know i
was fortunate enough to
you know be lucky to dodge and that was
hard for me because you know i'm like a
a spanish or a latin or
you know however they want to call it
today latino whatever in in a black gang
so i'm easy to point out
i'm easy to [ __ ] track down if what
for whatever i do
so you know whatever i did i had to be
very stealth-like
and
i got lucky and didn't you know have to
get on that run but plenty of my boys
they they had to go do that time in y a
and some of them went from y a to prison
like yeah you know
they graduated as we used to call it
jeez i remember getting the sense like
back in the day hanging out that there
was like
you know
something of a of a gang element that
was like
in your
like in our circle you know like kind of
circling around yeah you know like they
wanted they wanted to be down they
wanted to like hang out and uh
you know i remember i remember a guy
named soldier yeah soldier he's still
he's still around yeah yeah and then
there's my buddy dreamer i don't know
dreamer yeah oh my god dreamers
is he he's still around i think so yeah
there that's uh see that's the odds man
and see that's the thing you know when i
got out of gang banging people knew i
did and i never was one to like
overtly tell
people or show people like oh this is
this that gang uh and
as as we call it set tripping you know
when you're going out of your way to let
people know i never did that because for
me i didn't want to mix
that [ __ ] into the the music world
because i knew it would be a short run
for us
because you know when you got enemies
out there and now you're [ __ ]
flashing on them you're gonna have a
short run you you've got a big target on
your back and you've got to be
constantly dodging that so i let it all
go and i never had any problems with
anybody that was banging on the other
side after that you know what i mean we
i've always got along with any other
artist that were actual gang bangers
on the other side
always cool you know no disrespect never
but our crew
that we roll with is comprised from
people from different neighborhoods
who you know we might they might have
been a [ __ ] and now i'm a blood over
here this he might have been a mexican
gang banger or whatever we all roll
together that's that's the dynamic of
our crew is that it's comprised of
different right folks from different
streets here in in california so when
you step to us you're stepping to not
just us
right and i think that's why no one ever
really stepped to us like that one
we never were with the chips on our
shoulders like yeah come [ __ ] with us
and see what happens i think that's well
put you know thank god we were always
just chill
right for sure was there a moment that
you were like i gotta get out of this or
did it just kind of trickle away in some
way or like how does that work when i
chose the music
i knew that i could not bring the gang
banging in so i just had a talk with my
close circle of homies and said hey i'm
gonna go do this
go do it
handle that [ __ ] nice and it was as
simple as that it wasn't like i you know
i had to make a speech to 200
[ __ ] and like hey man um look
they understood and they supported me
and they had my back
in the powerpoint presentation
this is what i'm gonna do in the next
business plan yeah yeah and now check
your slide three we got you know and and
not for nothing i mean they knew i was
trying to do something positive and for
me i was indoctrinated in gangbang and i
didn't i wasn't trying to get out
i wasn't even trying to do the music
anymore like
mugs send and and melo came to me one
day and says hey um
melo's got a record deal we need you to
help us write some [ __ ]
come back and help us write
and i didn't even think i could
at that point because i had been so
invested in in the streets at that point
like uh what am i gonna do we're gonna
make no money doing that
dude
wow and um they're like well what do you
got to lose
and i think you know like
i i want to be careful not to kiss your
ass but but the way the [ __ ] rap is
people like the sound gets popular and
everybody's just sounds the [ __ ] same
it kind of drives me nuts it happens now
today still yeah dude absolutely more
today than ever more than ever yeah more
today than ever and dude i just love
like
how unique you've always been in your in
your art you know like and
dude you're to to to hear you say
that you doubted if you could write dope
[ __ ] just it just confuses me man well
yeah you know cause i hadn't written
anything in a long time and i did most
certainly didn't know how to write a
song yet i knew how to write raps
like i was good at writing my delivery
sucked i wasn't that good
but they knew i could write and they
needed help writing
and so i came back and i did two songs
for mello's first album i think it was
uh river cubanos and uh tacopella or
some [ __ ] like this and they were okay
songs if you listen to them now you're
like
all right
but what it did for me was it made me
realize that i could still do it i could
still write and it sort of i got bitten
by the bug like [ __ ]
the studio [ __ ] is kind of cool
and and you know at that time he was
working with delicious vinyl so in and
out of the studio would come young mc or
[ __ ] tone loke and they were cool
with us they did you know they they were
always
always very cool with us they knew i was
a gang banger so maybe that was
part of it
just be cool with this dude because i
don't know
um
certain politeness comes with that but
you know i've always maintained respect
no matter what even if there were a [ __ ]
or whatever i never got out
of pocket with anyone in the studio
because this was business this is not
that place for that [ __ ] so i was always
focused and i was learning as i was
going along there but
i found myself wanting to be in the
studio more than on the corner
and not because of the safety because i
didn't even think about that because i
was still strapping
you know i i was we were all like
cowboys for like
i i don't know maybe
up until maybe
10 years ago we stopped like you know
cowboying it but like
we would we all of us no matter who was
with us so when we were sitting at the
rainbow oh yeah there was at least five
guns
always present
i mean i would believe that there were
plenty of guns around you i had one on
my hip every time
you know i was a real cowboy in that
sense you know um because old habits die
hard yeah you know i mean but
i you know again i realized realized i
could not bring this [ __ ] so it but for
me it wasn't the safety it was the
creative part like oh [ __ ] i'm actually
doing this
and this is stuff we
we thought of when we were
you know a few years back listening to
run dmc and this and that and the other
like
and and so you know that's when i made
my choice i was like you know what i'm
going to do this
and and i mean to be fair man you guys
[ __ ] blew up dude like on that black
sunday thing i mean it wasn't like an
accident that that i started i mean that
[ __ ] was everywhere
and back when there was so much money in
music oh yeah
we had no clue it was going to blow up
we didn't know the first album would
blow
we were just hoping that
[ __ ] would like it we liked it
and we thought it was different
and for a west coast group
people took us for it for east coast
group they you know because
everybody was was trying to sound like
um well not trying to sound but very
influenced by nwa yeah you know and
we noticed that on the west coast if you
didn't sound like that
record companies weren't going to give
you any run
and we weren't we didn't want to sound
like that in spite of my you know me
being
a gang banger or coming out of that [ __ ]
i didn't want to sound like all this
gangster rap [ __ ] that was happening
because we would not be different than
anything else and mug's style of
production was definitely not that it
was more east coast
based right so we found a way to marry
you know the east coast and the west
coast mentality into this group
from mugs into the experiences of send
dog and myself
and all that [ __ ] and melding it into
what became our sound what became our
culture and all that [ __ ] and you know
it was a slow going you know on the
first album it was like six months
before anybody took notice to who we
were because we put out the single funky
feel one and how i could just kill a man
now it was a double a side
meaning that
um the record company could say this is
the side we're rocking right here funky
phil ones but
it's a double a side if you djs want to
flip it it's all good
but they were banking on funky phil one
because it's less controversial
it's not saying how i could just kill a
man
and
so
so they were they were banking on that
but it was going slow and
out of nowhere one of the new york dj's
maybe even in in the colleges that might
have been stretching babito
they flipped the record and they start
playing killing man and all of a sudden
boom the the momentum changes people
start talking about us naughty by nature
takes us on tour they were our boys
and they could they heard our album and
they knew what we were capable of so
they were like look we're gonna we're
gonna bring you on the road with us they
had the number one single at the time
with opp
and then killman starts to catch
on mix shows and they pull us off the
road they as in sony pull us off the
road to do to kill the man and hand on
the pump video and then kill a man
explodes with the video
chuck d and them uh the bomb squad are
doing the movie soundtrack for juice
they want to use how i could just kill a
man in the pivotal scene between tupac
and omar reps
at the end where they're chasing each
other through the club
and
that [ __ ] blew that song
like way the [ __ ] up you know and we did
not anticipate that i didn't anticipate
it i did not
see any of that coming in
you know so it's the album's now
catching momentum six months later it
had dropped off the charts
popped right back up we were i think we
entered at 270 or 200 or what no we
entered at 170
dropped off
and then we shot all the way the [ __ ]
back up and
when we were releasing black sunday the
the first album finally popped up into
the top five
and as we released black sunday we had a
number one album in black sunday and a
number five album wow wow original album
and no no hip-hop group had done that
at that point we were the first to do
that huge yeah i mean
so
it kind of reframes the thought i'd
rather be in the studio than on the
corner
[ __ ] day man like you know it was it
was a time i invested in myself in terms
of or instead of letting myself go
into
deeper into this [ __ ] because there's
only you know three three paths maybe
four
as a gang banger prison's one right the
grave is the other
life in a wheelchair or you're smart
enough to get the [ __ ] out and
you know that's not an easy task that's
not an easy task because
no one wants to hire a gang banger
to this job or that job it's a hard run
well right and the gangs don't exactly
just like uh
give you several depending on who you
are and what you know and what you've
done they don't always want to let you
go especially if you're somebody who is
well respected in that scientology yeah
if you're if you're well respected in
this life where you call shots and
people and and other [ __ ] fear
you they don't want to let you go
because then other [ __ ] think
oh they lost that guy they're crying it
might be kind of weak
and you know so those guys yeah that
they're hard-pressed to stay in
it's got to be tough to like
you know to kind of coming from that
whole scene and then
like you're like all over mtv like you
know like fully mainstream radio play
like celebrities left and right you know
are you like is this cool that i'm doing
this
oh you know like it was all new to me i
was just sort of soaking it in like
like this [ __ ] is unbelievable i can't
believe we're here you know like through
through that whole through the whole
first
you know five years i was just sort of
like
are we is this are we really here
and then that verse on the the stanconia
like that was just a whole other heyday
huh yeah yeah i was frankly surprised
that that uh
that they called me for that because you
know i didn't know that we were on their
radar like that i mean we were mutual
fans of outcast too but you know to get
called up to to knock one down with them
i mean [ __ ] that was like i mean it was
incredible yeah it was i got i got a
platinum plaque
for that [ __ ] one salute to y'all for
that thank you dude it's it's it's so
killer man and you know like it's it's
sort of sort of like uh
you know
unrelated but but i watched this
documentary on hulu about the tekashi 69
kid yes and what's so
[ __ ] shocking about that
is that he had
at the same time he had like
five
hit songs on the like billboard 100.
he's got all this money coming in
and he's just cutting people out of his
business who are like heavy [ __ ] shot
callers
in in like serious
[ __ ] gang [ __ ] and like
just from my experience when when when
money's coming in and then you tell
someone hey you're off my team man i'm
not going to commission you anymore oh
yeah no that's
that was the most fascinating thing
about that how he thought he was gonna
pull that off smoothly especially
especially the dudes that like you know
first at first funded him and put them
under his pain and gave him that
protection
and you know i'll say this you know in
in terms of marketing himself
whether you love him or hate him he's a
genius for how he flips absolutely um in
terms of the street [ __ ] yeah you know
he violated on many fronts um but
you know
it's
that situation is tough because it's
it's it's like
yeah you know he probably realized they
were digging in his pockets in such a
way that like he should have been
getting more
maybe as an artist and he felt like
now i'm getting all of this right it's
just crazy and you know not to like
like even
talk [ __ ] or anything it was just a
fascinating story yeah it is
that's what uh you know and i thought
that documentary was really impressive
too no doubt man it it is because it
shows you the story of how he makes
himself did and and and kudos to the kid
for being a [ __ ] marketing genius oh
yeah you know like him him uh
telling on
on his partners and all that [ __ ] i mean
you know that's for other people to
judge i mean some people that that are
street folks are like nah that that just
doesn't fly that's against the rules
cause if you're playing the game then
you know
right you know you know what the
possibilities are
and you have to be okay with that and
you gotta man up
if you're playing in the
streets and you're not going to adhere
to the rules
then yeah you're going to have that
target on your back you know what i mean
and
that's he's got to forever live with
police protection for right now you know
or
i don't know how long he's going to be
under witness protection or whatever but
i don't know how well he does under
witness yeah i don't know how effective
that that protection is well it's he's
okay for now
but he's a guy who who now has had light
and is used to it and wants it and seeks
it and can't let go of it for his own
good right because he keeps winning like
people that aren't gang bangers aren't
street folks they're like well yeah so
what if he [ __ ] ratted those people
out i mean they were [ __ ] with him
they were getting over on him they tried
to rob him they tried to they pissed her
yeah they pissed the whipped him
they don't get
the the commitment you make in this life
they don't get that they're just fans
and you know god bless them they you
know
realistically if you're a civilian yeah
you don't adhere to those same rules if
you're in the life you must
if you don't
then
what what he did that causes a target on
your back happens and that you know he
he knows that
that's why he's he's living the way he
is now but it's i know it's eating him
inside because he can't be as free as he
was in terms of going out and causing a
commotion and you know stirring up the
base and [ __ ] like that the tougher part
is man like uh i you know being
exposed to the light being like you know
like acquainted with the celebrity and
all the shine
and and uh and but people won't [ __ ]
with them yeah and not for nothing he
had good songs
you don't
that's that's the [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
like for for as much as he annoyed
people he actually had talent yeah you
know and he constructed his character
and and made it pop as
the street [ __ ] that he got caught up in
sort of yeah it taints all that for sure
but as an artist he was doing his thing
i mean was it my cup of tea i wasn't
going out of my way to [ __ ] with it but
when i did hear it like yeah that's cool
he had he had some [ __ ] yeah but it's
just all the other [ __ ] can you look
past that can you accept that and you
know my my old self
in terms of
where i came from now that's
unacceptable
man i'm sad hey go real quick let me ask
you who's your top five favorite rappers
uh i use controversial questions no i
usually narrow it to a three but i could
go five um so at the the pinnacle you
know and it could go in any order for me
but
realistically it should be krs at the
top for me
um eminem
jay-z
rock kim
um
kuji rap
and uh you know i did i did a track with
cool g rap
one of the sickest in the world man and
steve-o
your cashmere dude
i remember i brought poked the person to
damon dash's office and i played it for
him he said well i'm not gonna say
you're the next jay-z
oh my god that's great so those yeah
those are my guys right there man that
uh
and and and just i think like you know
for for talking about all the street
[ __ ] and all right like it's just that's
just not who you are now yeah yeah i
mean that would be
that would be a falsehood to be talking
[ __ ] like i'm still out there gang
banging and right you know um
living that life i definitely ain't
doing that [ __ ] and even when you were i
think he played it all pretty cleverly
yes because here's the thing right um
and they do it more so now than they
than they used to but
i mean the feds in law enforcement are
listening to everything you're doing
they're watching everything you're
posting
if you're a hip-hop artist
because
some some hip-hop artists will tell on
themselves in a song yeah trying to be
too graphic about it
i want i want i want to validate
me by telling you some [ __ ] i did right
and
you know you might think oh well it's a
song no one's really going to take it
serious but guess what the [ __ ]
that are the law enforcement they take
it serious and if there's a case pending
on some [ __ ] you mentioned that sort of
links you to that
guess what
they're coming at you so
you know you can't you know you'd be
stupid to tell on yourself and tell a
story that is completely
full of all truths if you're going to
tell a story that did happen
you kind of you might want to shake it
up a little bit or not even [ __ ] tell
that story right because realistically
you know you could put yourself
or your boys or somebody in a twist for
something you said that
you know that needs resolution in terms
of a case right right so
yeah man
you got some guys that just they don't
think about it and they'll put
themselves in a [ __ ] twist by telling
on themselves other guys that are being
really graphic and and telling you this
story as if it [ __ ] happened
yesterday that [ __ ] is made up they
ain't never lived that life they ain't
been one day through it because you
wouldn't be saying such a graphic
[ __ ] story that's true
right you know what i mean because you'd
be telling on yourself
it's called dry
snitching wow we're learning so much
today yeah i love it man this dude this
has been so killer man i don't think we
you know i i
i think we're good to go man we
this we don't normally go much more than
an hour anyway all good man thank you
for having me brother
man yeah what an honor anytime man
anytime like uh
just having you even follow me on
instagram's at honor oh come on man i
love it
i love it dude
so we'll jump on yours you do this [ __ ]
every day yeah well when i'm not on tour
we do uh the dr green thumb podcast live
monday through friday so wow yeah i mean
i i've been doing it for 12 years now
unbelievable we started um we started i
don't know if you remember this
streaming service called stick m it was
a rival to uh the other one ustream
right and stick cam
you know we got in with some people down
there and they would feature our our um
it wasn't known as a podcast back then
but it was just a live stream tom green
weber right
and i was like pretty much one of the
first
so-called celebrities on there like
actually streaming you know [ __ ]
monday through friday and we sort of
took that format from there and just
applied it to what we are doing today
because stick cam eventually went away
but
we built our platform to keep going in
case they went down so that we didn't
have to go to a ustream or anywhere else
we used live stream for a time just to
use their player but
yeah man i mean we've been we've been
doing this a long time we used to just
do post first you know what i mean we're
doing
filming it and and you know doing all
the edits and then putting it up and
then we felt like it would be better to
to engage live because we have our chat
room there and we we heavily engage with
them they ask questions at the end to to
us or make comments or give shout outs
and you know it it's it's a fun [ __ ]
time man i swear like
you know
building the platform it took a while
but
i i realized from doing radio that this
was another version of of that it's not
necessarily the radio but because
they're they're getting to see you now
but it's sort of the same so i you know
i i decided i'm going to take this [ __ ]
serious and i'm going to make it a
schedule rather than something i do once
or twice a month
you know so it it's been growing and uh
man it all started with the smoke box
yeah
yeah because the smoke box not everybody
wanted to get in they were afraid
right if you're not a smoker they don't
want to get in and if they're kind of a
smoker they're afraid of getting too lit
so i created the dr green thumb podcast
so that people that didn't smoke
could come sit in even if we were
smoking they didn't have to you know
it's optional yeah i apologize for it
don't apologize for nothing that's why
we made this show so that
because because i we have friends i
can't i can't breathe this year man i
know
so we you know we have friends like same
thing right that like they want to come
in but they can't smoke and so we made
the show optional
for people that if they wanted to smoke
or didn't want to sweat i was touched by
the opera to have your personal joint
roller roll me a joy
did you put out a craigslist ad for that
or how do you find your personal joint
role
you know like the guys that that came in
to work for b real tv um from day one i
taught them all how to roll
so they've become expert rollers and now
they're trying to hold their own classes
and call themselves
dude
you know hey dr green thumb university
come sign up i love it dude
i love it man well dude thank you so
much and i'm start to jump on your thing
hey let's turn this one around and make
this one next okay
yeah dude that was like so dope man be
real just such a bro
and uh you know what i want to just say
thank you guys not only for sticking
around to the end of the episode like i
always do
but thank you for supporting
like the sponsors of the show man i mean
dude the fact that we are able to do
this and just like get behind these
companies that we dig
and you guys obviously are digging it
man like and i just want to say thank
you man thank you for supporting the
podcast by getting behind the sponsors
of the podcast i mean hey man
life is good dude
and i'm stoked so
maybe i'm gonna [ __ ]
chew up a bluetooth and
do some [ __ ]